hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
tagen welt ich hab euch ja bereits vor
ein paar wochen versprochen dass ich
zeige wie ich meine lkw torte gebacken
habe und das ganze ist auch schon etwa
sechs wochen her
die torte habe ich nämlich bereits vor
meiner türkei-urlaub gefilmt und ich
hab's einfach bisher nicht geschafft
weil es ein sehr komplexes video wurde
weil ich sehr viel filmmaterial hatte
und das ganze dann eben auf 20 25
minuten zurechtschneiden musste ich habe
insgesamt für die torte etwa 15 stunden
gebraucht weil ich einfach viel mit
details gearbeitet habe und habe euch
jetzt hier dem mieter auch nicht gezeigt
wie ich den teig gebacken habe weil ich
euch ja bereits schon öfter gezeigt habe
mir meine tykwer ich habe hier in meinem
video den bananen wirkungen genommen
habe eine saat meter genau gemacht und
auch etwas zucker kleber benutzt wird
also drei videos mit den rezepten werde
ich euch unten in der infobox verlinken
wo er auch zum beispiel die ganzen
produkte finden können und einfach
beitreten
während ihr dieses video anschauen weil
es wahrscheinlich schon beim nächsten
video drehen und zwar habe ich jetzt am
wochenende die 100.000 abonnenten bei
youtube erreicht und ich habe ja gesagt
dass sich da ein eigenes video dazu
treten
und das kommt am morgen online und ich
bitte sagen ich starte mit der torte
ihr solltet auf jeden fall den editors
nach macht viel zeit mitnehmen auch viel
geduld
bevor ich eine torte backen mache ich
mir natürlich immer zuerst eine
zeichnung damit ich weiß was ich machen
will
heute gibt es einen lkw mit einem
anhänger und dafür mache ich mir auch
immer ganz genau zeichnungen damit ich
die ganz genauen maße habe der lkw wird
jetzt 18 cm lang
also dieser anhänger das fahrerhaus 6 cm
und breite ist so etwa 10 5 cm
da steht jetzt zwar noch 9 aber ich habe
jetzt hier das abgeändert so dass ich
dann vorne
die front dieses fahrerhaus und hinten
dann noch zwei anhänger
das fahrerhaus habe ich mir dann auch
nochmal maßstabgetreu als in
originalgröße aufgezeichnet so dass ich
das später dann als schablone verwenden
konnte für den kuchen habe ich dann für
das fahrerhaus und die anhänger jeweils
eine schablone aus papa gemacht die ich
dann später auch als unterlage verwenden
konnte ich habe für meinen fall ist
einen banalen kuchen gebacken und hab
das 1 5-fache rezept einfach in meinem
back rahmen gebacken und habe mit hilfe
der schablonen jetzt einfach den teig
zurechtgeschnitten
die krümel müsst ihr kind nicht
wegschmeißen
die könnt ihr einfach weiter verwenden
um zb camp auszumachen
mir war der kuchen jetzt nicht hoch
genug deswegen habe ich den teil des
fahrerhauses nochmal abgeschnitten und
habe dieses jetzt mehrmals
ausgeschnitten damit das fahrerhaus auch
wirklich hoch genug war
die teile habe ich dann mit
aprikosenmarmelade zusammengesetzt und
festgeklebt
als nächstes habe ich den kuchen
kühl gestellt und die reifen vorbereitet
und zwar habe ich hier für meine
holzstäbchen genommen damit die reifen
einfach gleichmäßig dick werden
hab sie zurecht geschnitten die waren
war etwa 1 cm breit und konnte dann mit
einem ausstecher die runden kreise
ausstechen so dass die kreise dann in
die vertiefungen reinpassen
bei mir war das etwas knapp bemessen das
heißt wenn er es auch nach macht mit ihr
die vertiefungen bei dem anhänger etwas
größer gestalten
die reifen habe ich dann mit etwas
aprikosen monate gestrichen
der werbung
und habe sie dann ins gefrierfach
gestellt die marmelade hilft das später
der kommt dann schön kräftig
nach etwa 30 minuten im gefrierfach
konnte ich sie dann mit etwas kann das
bestreichen und alle rezepte die hier
benutze verlinkt ich euch in einer
infobox also auch den bananen kuchen und
auch das kann als rezept und so konnte
ich mit hilfe einer mini palette alle
reifen schön einstreichen
mit einer großen fink die palette habe
ich dann meinen fahrerhaus und den
anhänger glatt gestrichen
zuerst einmal eine schicht damit die
krümel gebunden werden konnten dass es
ganz schön viel arbeit weil der lkw ganz
viele vertiefungen hat da könnt ihr euch
also ruhig auch etwas zeit nehmen und
immer mal wieder den kuchen zwischendrin
kühl stellen
mit einer winkel palette kommt ihr ganz
schön in die kleinen ecken hinein und
mit den großen paletten und mit teig
schavan könnt ihr oben und am rand die
seiten ganz streichen
hier seht ihr wie ich den zweiten
anhänger gemacht habe auch hierfür habe
ich dann extra eine schablone gemacht
und so ist es bestreichen etwas
einfacher wenn ihr den kuchen dann auf
etwas höheres stellt unschön an den
seiten gut dran kommt
für die ladefläche habe ich einen
behälter genommen hier war das jetzt
eine kriegs packung und habe sie mit
backpapier eingeschlagen und dieses habe
ich dann als schablone genommen
für meine ladefläche wenn ihr die
gleichen maße macht wie ich könnt ihr
genauso eine packung verwenden oder ihr
nehmt einfach eine packung die gut auf
den anhänger draufpasst um die
ladefläche vorzubereiten habe ich weißen
fondant wald geknetet und habe dafür
meine hände mit panin eingefettet und
den weißen von land mit diesen passten
farben eingefärbt die man ganz toll aus
der turbo heraus zu sehen kann
dafür habe ich etwas grün und etwas geld
gemischt damit ich ein schönes hellgrün
hatte ich habe hier auch etwas cnc
verein geknetet so dass sich eine
modelliermasse hatte denn wenn man jetzt
nur von dort nimmt wird davon dann nicht
fest wenn man also eine feste form
möchte muss man cmc ein kneten damit die
vorm austrocknen kann
dieses habe ich dann ausgerollt und
zurechtgeschnitten
mit hilfe der tölzer habe ich dann schön
gerade geschnitten und habe einfach den
karton als schablone verwendet
ringsherum habe ich etwa 2 cm platz
gelassen und so ein rechteck
ausgeschnitten
hier müsst ihr zuerst die ecken formen
die ich dann mit einer schere
abgeschnitten und sie dann mit etwas
kleber zusammengeklebt habe
mit einem messer habe ich dann die
kanten schön gerade abgeschnitten rings
herum und konnte so die ladefläche
trocknen lassen
ich habe das ganze wie gesagt an zwei
tagen gemacht besser ist es aber wenn
ihr die ladefläche zum beispiel schon
eine woche vorher macht damit sie
wirklich richtig schön hart wird
für die reifen habe ich schwarze
modelliermasse genommen und diese dünn
ausgerollt
und habe dann wieder hunde kreis auf
sich genommen
die etwa 1 cm im durchmesser größer
waren als meine reifen die ganz kalten
reifen konnte ich dann auf einem kreis
auflegen mit dem zweiten kreis bedecken
und ich habe dann etwas trüber geholt
damit glatt wird und habe dann die
ränder schön eingeklappt und da ist es
nicht schlimm wenn die ränder sich nicht
berühren
denn da kommt dann noch einen streifen
drüber
mit einem teig hölzchen habe ich dann
die mitte etwas markiert damit ich da
die fällige rein machen konnte
hier könnte man auch einen etwas
größeren teig balken nehmen
anschließend habe ich eine struktur
rolle genommen und dieses ist so eine
struktur rolle diesen mauerwerk
darstellen soll und damit habe ich
nochmal den fondant strukturiert und mit
diesem dann streifen zurechtgeschnitten
die ich dann um meine reifen herum
gelegt habe
den streifen habe ich so breit
geschnitten kümmern reifen ist und ihn
dann
mit etwas zucker kleber am reifen
entlang fixiert
mit einem pinsel habe ich dann die
ränder etwas eingedrückt um den reifen
einfach etwas struktur zu geben
und habe anschließend mit einem
schaschlikspieß die ränder noch mal
schön eingedrückt
die reifen konnte ich dann so etwas
austrocknen lassen
anschließend habe ich mit einem loch
thüle nochmal kreise ausgestochen
und habe diese mit meiner silberfarbe
mit dem pulver mit einem pinsel schön
angemalt
so waren praktisch die felgen gestaltet
und mit ein paar einzelteilen wie zb
kleineren kreisen könnt ihr da noch ein
paar details reinsetzen
den lkw habe ich jetzt bereits schön
glatt gestrichen und da ist jetzt auch
richtig kalt und sehr fest soeben dass
ich ihn jetzt mit fondant überziehen
kann
dafür habe ich etwas grünen fondant
wieder weich geknetet habe ihn auf
wecker stärke mit meinem großen
ausbaustopp ausgerollt und ihr seht auch
dass ein ausfall starb richtig gut ist
weil da nichts dran kleben bleibt
das fahrerhaus wurde jetzt bei mir grün
und deswegen habe ich auch nur das
fahrerhaus mit dem von sand bedeckt beim
glattstreichen von rechteckigen sachen
müsst ihr immer darauf achten dass ihr
zuerst die ecken gestaltet also die
ecken platt macht und dann anschließend
die mitte und die seiten glatt streicht
nur so könnt ihr nämlich verhindern dass
ihr falken habt und es dauert auch
einfach seine zeit ihr arbeitet euch von
oben nach unten und so wird es mit der
zeit immer glatter
ringsherum konnte ich dann den übrigen
fondant erst mal glatt streichen und
dann die reste mit einem cutter schön
wegschneiden
der anhänger wurde von mir schwarz
gestaltet und deswegen habe ich dort
schwarzen fondant draufgelegt und diesen
genauso sorgfältig glatt gestrichen und
dann die reste abgeschnitten
am besten könnte damit eine modelle
werkzeug noch mal die ecken usw
richtig schön eckig gestalten und mit
einem pinsel lassen sich dann
anschließend die bäcker stärke reste
einfach abgetan
und das ist auch der große vorteil von
becker sterkel als nächstes habe ich
dann das fahrerhaus gestaltet und habe
mir hier zu den kleinen ausrutscher
abgenommen und die abstandshalter dran
gemacht habe schwarze blüten passte
genommen und mit dieser dann die
einzelteile zurechtgeschnitten angeklebt
habe ich alles wieder mit dem zucker
kleber den ich aus cnc und wasser
hergestellt habe
ich habe ich jetzt die shougang benutzt
um damit schöne streifen zu formen wie
es sehen könnt ist es mit dieser show
ganze anstrengend weil man viel kraft
braucht um den streifen auszudrücken und
ich bin hier bei immer noch auf der
suche nach einem besseren produkt habe
auch eins gefunden und werde dieses
hoffentlich bald erhalten
für die fenster habe ich wieder die
super kann benutzt und wieder mit
schwarzer blüten passte den rahmen
zurechtgeschnitten und diesen auch mit
zucker kleber festgeklebt
das backpapier habe ich etwas
eingefettet damit einfach der rahmen
schön drauf liegen bleibt und mit hilfe
eines lineares oder eines teig stäbchen
es geht auch kann man dann den rahmen
schön darauf basieren so dass der rahmen
auch richtig glatt und rechteckig wird
diesen müsst ihr dann vor der weiteren
verwendung erst einmal aushärten lassen
ihr könnt jetzt die scheiben entweder
aus sondern zubereiten oder so wie ich
aus zukam
ich habe das jetzt erst einmal
ausprobiert und zwar habe ich ganz
normal kristallzucker genommen und ihn
in der pfanne auflösen lassen und ihr
wisst ja auch dass man so auf karamel
herstellen und das war auch bei diesem
zucker das problem nämlich erlöst sich
in der pfanne auf und direkt im
anschluss fängt schon an zu
karamellisieren
das heißt da muss man richtig schnell
arbeiten damit man bevor der zucker zu
karamell wird überhaupt die form noch
lesen kann
ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal was ich
hier für probleme hatte zuerst einmal
hatte ich hier etwas wenig zucker
benutzt und hatte somit probleme
überhaupt die frau auszufüllen und wir
schon sehen könnt ist die farbe der geld
und noch bevor ich die scheibe schön
dünn aus streichen kann wird das
karamell schon fest und zieht fehlten
und ich habe einfach keine schönen ecken
mehr hinbekommen
alles hat man noch geklebt und ihr seht
auch die scheibe wurde nicht richtig
schön glatt und eben scheiben mäßig also
es waren viele risse auch drin
es hat viele fäden gezogen und nach etwa
30 sekunden könnte ich den zucker gar
nicht mehr weiter verarbeiten weil er
dann einfach schon wieder fest wurde
wenn man den zucker dann wieder auflöst
wieder natürlich immer dunkler und das
ist einfach der große nachteil von
normalem zucker
ich hab's dann noch versucht
auszubessern
aber das endergebnis habe mir natürlich
gar nicht gefallen
also habe ich noch eine andere methode
ausprobiert habe den zucker aufgelöst
und dir indirekt auf ein backpapier
ausgelegt und habe ihn erst einmal etwas
runter laufen lassen damit der dünner
wird und dann direkt im anschluss noch
bevor der zucker kalt wird habe ich
versucht das glas mit einem messer zu
schneiden
aber wie ihr sehen könnt funktioniert es
nicht richtig weil einfach das karamell
viel zu schnell kalt und daneben brüchig
wird also das glas dann einfach
gebrochen
also habe ich etwas isomalt genommen
dass es so eine puppe aus stoff und
dieser löst sich wirklich sehr gut auf
und bleibt dabei auch durchsichtig ich
sage euch einfach mal wie dieser sich
auflöst
so konnte ich ihn dann praktisch nehmen
und in meinen rahmen hineinfühlen ohne
dass man mir währenddessen schon fest
wurde
was sieht man kann ihn auch richtig
schön glatt streichen und dazu komplett
transparent das heißt meine scheibe
sieht auch wirklich aus wie eine scheibe
weil man durch sie hindurch sehen kann
so habe ich jetzt die große scheibe und
auch zwei kleine scheiben gemacht diese
müssen dann erst einmal ausruhen und
kalt werden und in der zeit habe ich
mich wieder um das fahrerhaus gekümmert
und habe dafür einfach ein paar
schablonen gemacht um mehr die teile
zurechtzuschneiden die teile gebe ich
immer mit zucker kleber an und verwende
ständig mein ideal um die rahmen und
linien auch richtig gerade zu machen
und hier habe ich mir wieder die schufa
gang genommen um ein fahrstreifen
zurechtzuschneiden und noch kleine
einzelteile an zu brennen
und ihr werdet ihr doch sehen je mehr
einzelteile man nimmt umso schöner wird
die torte mit luft kühlen kann man zum
beispiel ein paar schrauben kennzeichnen
ich habe dann auch noch die lichter und
die blinker gestaltet und diese
angeklebt und das habe ich jetzt alles
aus blüten passte gemacht damit diese
schnell fest wird und hart wird und ich
leichte damit arbeiten
das nummernschild habe ich wieder aus
weißer blüten passte geformt und habe
ich hier für meinen stanzer genommen und
zwar kanada die buchstaben einzeln
heraus nehmen und beispielsweise einen
namen zusammen setzen und diesen dann
irgendwo rein stimmen
weiter ging es mit der lkw ladefläche
dafür habe ich mir noch mal ausrücken
passte ein paar rechtecke zurecht
geschnitten und diese dann um den kasten
herum gelegt und trocknen lassen damit
er einfach schönere ecken und kanten hat
für das fahrerhaus habe ich dann noch
die türen gestaltet und hierfür die
kleinen fenster genommen
diese aufgeklebt und anschließend die
türen an das fahrerhaus angeklebt hier
könnt ihr auch noch mal den unterschied
sehen zwischen den normalen fenstern und
den karamell fenstern
diese werden dann auch wieder mit zucker
kleber angeklebt
den zweiten anhänger habe ich genauso
gestaltet ihn mit fondant überzogen und
etwas fest werden lassen
für die reifen habe ich dann noch die
abdeckung gemacht aus grauer blüten
passte
ob diese zwei zentimeter breit und zehn
zentimeter lang gestaltet und über
meinen ausbau stark gelegt zum aushalten
nun habe ich jetzt alle einzelteile
fertig und kann den lkw zusammensetzen
wie ich meinen kate bord gemacht habe
zeige ich euch am ende des videos
ich werde jetzt meinen lkw etwas erhöht
setzen und habe mir deswegen ein paar
kartons stücke zusammen gesteckt und
diese etwa 2 cm hoch geformt
ich hatte keinen doppelseitigen käfer
deswegen habe ich klebeband etwas
zusammengerollt und konnte so den lkw
und den anhänger draufsetzen für die
reifen habe ich logistics genommen um
die reifen dann eben an die torte
anzubringen habe ich sie in die torte
reingestellt und dann ab gemessen wo der
reifen auf den logistik trifft und habe
den reifen dann einfach eingelegt da
habe es auch nicht geklebt sondern
konnte das einfach auf den logistik
aufschließen
und das weiß auch der grund warum ich
die torte in die höhe gesetzt habe weil
ich nämlich wollte dass es so echt wie
möglich aussieht und die torte nicht auf
dem boden feststellt
anschließend habe ich noch die schutz
haben für die reifen auf bisher und habe
dann aus grauer blüten passte noch ein
paar kalksandsteine geformt indem ich
sie einfach zurecht geschnitten habe
die lkw ladefläche habe ich dann mit
etwas racing angeklebt und konnte dann
die steine hineinfühlen
die habe ich auch mit etwas realizing
festgeklebt und vorher mit einem pinsel
abgestoppt damit die bäcker stärke
wegkommt das skateboard habe ich dann
auch mit realizing bestrichen und es
dann mit zerkrümelt maritimes belegt
damit es einfach etwas leichter und
schöner aussieht
und so sah dann die fertige torte
aussehen ich habe noch ein paar
einzelteile dran gemacht wie
beispielsweise die spiegel habe noch ein
paar buchstaben ausgestochen um damit
die torte zu verzieren und habe
natürlich hinten noch die zahl 60
bei der liebe christi an 60 jahre alt
wurde
das skateboard war insgesamt 60 cm lang
und meine torte war ungefähr wie ihr
sehen könnt 50 cm lang war also eine
richtig große torte und hier zeige ich
euch noch mal wie ich das skateboard
zusammengesetzt habe und zwar habe ich
dafür styropor dummies genommen und
diese mit einem großen dort zusammen
gesteckt und dann mit packpapier
eingeleitet
ihr habt gesehen es war sehr viel arbeit
diese torte zu backen
zumal 3d trockenheit und aufwendiger
sind weil man einfach eben komplexer
gestalten und sie muss von allen seiten
schild aussehen aber ihr seht auch aber
es hat sich gelohnt und traurig auf
jeden fall an so ein auto oder an dem
lkw auf diese weise könnt ihr übrigens
auch autos gestalten also zum beispiel
auch so eine karte sondern 3d wurde das
funktioniert alles nach demselben
prinzip einfach die torte etwas anbieten
damit sie eben echte aussieht und dann
die reifen schöne an den rand ihr müsst
euch auf jeden fall immer diese
schablone machen und dann funktioniert
es auch ich hoffe natürlich dass euch
dieses rezept getan hat und dass ihr
eine kommentare was und meine bewertung
geht
ich hoffe dass ich euch damit helfen
konnte und einfach viele fragen geklärt
habe und freue mich schon aufs nächste
mal bis bald
und warum man eine brief ablage in der
küche haben sollte wie meine küchen
organisation aussieht warum ich meinen
waschbecken richtig schrecklich finde
oder warum ich zwei backöfen aber keine
mikrowelle haare erfahrt ihr in meinem
tischen organisations video was schon
bald kommt